Transcriber: Eylül Hürcan
Gözden geçirme: Başak Gökdaş
Ich bin ein guter Mensch.
Ben iyi bir insanım.
Neye göre, kime göre?
Etiketlerden özgürleşmek diyorum.
Adım Akasya Asıltürkmen.
Bunlar da benim etiketlerim.
Oyuncuyum, yazarım, eğitmenim.
Seslendirmenim, içerik üreticisiyim.
Son yıllarda yaptığım ve en severek
yaptığım işlerimden biri.
Etiketlerimden biri.
Aynı zamanda girişimciyim. Ve salatalık
severim desem ve bunu da üstüne yazsam ve
bunu herkes görse bir süre
sonra şöyle hissedeceğim.
Ama beni herkes salatalığı ne kadar
sevdiğimle ilgili tanıyor. O yüzden
ben şimdi birdenbire salatalıktan
nefret edersem hakkımda ne düşünürler?
Etiketlerden özgürleşmek.
Aslında bu konuşmayı hazırlarken
başlığım şuydu:
Etiketlerden kurtulmak.
Ama etiketlerden kurtulmak?
İnsan nelerden kurtulur?
Kötü bulduğu şeylerden, hoşlanmadığı
şeylerden,
ağır gelen durumlardan kurtulur.
Ama özgürleşmek.
Benim onlarla ilgili bir şikayetim yok.
Hepsini çok seviyorum.
Gittiğim bütün yolları ,
dolaştığım yerleri,
varoluşumu ve beni
bu aleme getiren her şeyi.
Bütün mesleklerimi, kimliklerimi,
etiketlerimi seviyorum.
Ama bazen onların içinde sıkışıp
kalmak istemiyorum.
Bu çoğumuz için geçerli.
Neden?
Oh, yok evet.
Peki biz neden tanımlarız?
Tanımlamamızın bir sebebi var.
Kendimizi iyi hissetmek için, güvende
hissetmek için, rahat hissetmek için.
Çünkü dışarıdan bize çok fazla etki gelir.
O etkilerin arasında ve belirsizliğin
içerisinde kendimizi tehlikede hissederiz.
Tehlikede hissetmemek için insanları ,
durumları , ortamı , havayı sürekli
olarak tanımlarız.
Tanımladığımız ve onlara bir isim
taktığımız sürece kendimizi
daha iyi hissederiz.
Bu böyle bir insan.
Ahmet çok iyi biri.
Zehra çok dürüsttür, çok iyidir,
çok tatlıdır.
İsmail Bey Öğretmen çok başarılı bir
öğretmen, girişimci, kadın girişimci,
erkek girişimci?
Yani onlara girişimci diyoruz direkt.Hatta
bir arkadaşım şöyle
bir şey söylemişti.
Kendisi müzik yapımcısı ve kendisi kadın
müzik yapımcısı,
“kadın müzik yapımcısı diyorlar bana”
Bir sürü arkadaşım var.
Erkekler onlara erkek müzik
yapımcısı demiyorlar asla.
Ve benim başarmam nedense çok
büyük bir başarıymış,
″kadın haliyle″ bunu başarmış
gibi algılanıyor.
Çünkü bazı kompleksleri biz de yine
etiket üzerinden tamamlıyoruz.
Mesela gençlere ″genç, toy″ diyoruz
hemen değil mi?
Çünkü genç toy...
Halbuki az önce, ben bir arkadaşı izledim
ve gerçekten izlediğim
en iyi şeylerden biriydi.
Onların şu anda ulaştıkları bilgi,
onlara gelen bilgi, akan şey
bizim tecrübemizin çok üzerinde.
O yüzden artık daha fazla toyluk yok.
Bu sadece kendimizi rahatlatmak işi.
Peki, bakın bu yukarda gördüğünüz
bölümler.
Bu bölümlerin sadece bir
tanesinin ismi yazıyor.
İşletme, Ekonomi, Uluslararası İlişkiler,
Uluslararası İlişkiler...
Duyduğumda bana hep çok havalı gelmiştir.
Bu da mühendislik.
Bu mesleklerle ilgili söyleyeceğim şey şu
Ortak noktaları benim gözümde şu:
Akıllı kararsızlar bölümleri.
Yani kafam çalışıyor.
Üniversiteye girmem gerekiyor.
Üniversiteye girmem şart.
Hele benim ülkemin şartlarında.
Sizin de bildiğiniz gibi üniversite
neredeyse bir zorunluluk.
Hiç alternatif olmadı.
Çünkü Avrupa'daki, Amerika'daki
çocuk ne yapıyor?
Lisesi bittikten sonra iki
sene dünyayı geziyor.
Zaten bizde emeklilik bile çok farklı .
Bu konuşmayı hazırlarken, emeklilikle
ilgili, Türkiye’de içerik ve yurt dışında
içerik aramaya karar verdim.
Emeklilik yazdım.
Bizde sadece emekli kuyruğu, yaşlı
amcalar, teyzeler... gibi şeyler çıktı .
Retired(emeklinin ingilizcesi) yazdığımda,
gezen insanlar,
yaşlılar mutlu, hep beraber yamaç paraşütü
yapıyorlar, dünyayı geziyorlar çıktı .
Bir de öyle bir durum var.
Ama bu mesleklerin hepsi akıllı ,
kararsız bölümleri.
Gerçekten de ben o kadar çok reklam
şirketlerinde çalışan, uluslararası
ilişkiler mezunu tanıyorum ki ve hatta
ekonomi bitirmiş olanlar.
Boğaziçi ekonomiyi bitirmiş.
Gerçekten ders notları o kadar zor ki.
Zaten İngilizce...
O İngilizceyi benim çözmeme imkanı yok.
Onlar da bunun için ekstra okuyorlar.
Ama yine de, bu bölümleri okurken bu
insanlar şöyle bir şey yaşıyorlar ve bu da
çok değerli.
Bunu da söylemek istiyorum.
Okula gitmek iyidir.
Çünkü
okulda, öğrencilerime de hep söylüyorum
size öğrencilik için tanınmış bir
zaman vardır. O zaman o zamanı
değerlendirebilirsiniz diyorum onlara.
En azından.Bir şeye sıkışmak yerine.
Ama yine de bana tuhaf geliyor.
Bir kimliğin arkasına girebilmek için,
sırf ipin ucunu bulmak için
aslında çok genç
yaşta bir mesleğin kişisi olmak ve
diğerlerini düşünememek bile.
Ama bu sadece eğitimler
için geçerli değil.
Geçenlerde çok eski ve çok sevdiğim
bir filme şöyle bir göz attık.
Şimdi bu konuşmanın ardından
bu slayt size değişik gelecek.
Züğürt Ağa.
Neden?
Çünkü şöyle bir düşününce
Züğürt Ağa’nın hikayesini
herhalde hepiniz biliyorsunuzdur.
Kendisi bir köy ağası dır ama aslında
köy ağasının bile devri geçmiştir.
Köyleri yöneten ağaların
yönetici olmalarının sebebi,
büyük bir toprak biriminin sahibi
olmaları ve bunları sürmeleri için
insanlara para vermeleri...pardon yani
onları çalıştırmaları ve ekinden onlara
pay vermeleri ve Züğürt Ağa en nihayetinde
alaşağı edilir, bir nevi
aslında köyünü satmak zorunda kalır ve
büyük şehre göçmek durumundadır.
Züğürt Ağa'nın özgürlüğe giden
yolculuğunda kendini ortaya atması
gerekir ve atar.
Haraptar Market diye bir market açar,
bakkal bile değil.
Market.
Bir ağa, market yönetmekten
ne anlayabilir?
Tabii ki görkemli bir şekilde batar
kendini ortaya atmak mı
yoksa kendini ortaya koymak mı ?
Birkaç kişi daha dener, kendine yaraşır
işler denemeye çalışır.
Hepsi şehirde ona yaraşır olduğunu
ağa kimliğine yaraşır
olduğunu düşündüğü mesleklerdir.
Lakin hiçbirinde başarılı olamaz.
Ve en nihayetinde ağalığının temsili olan,
bunun aynı zamanda oyunculuk ya da
yönetmenler için de dramaturjik
bir sembolik anlamı vardır.
Çizmelerine bakar ve kalan
son değerli şeyini....
Sürekli çiftçilerin fırçaladı, boyadığı,
o değerli ağır çizmelerini satar
ve kendine
bir tezgah ve kıyma.
Artık ne yapması gerekiyorsa,
yani çiğ köfte yapmak için
gerekli malzemeleri alır.
Neden çiğ köfte yapmak için
gerekli malzemeleri alır?
Çünkü köydeki bütün özel günlerde
kurbanlar kesilirken,ağa hep çiğ köfte
yoğurur ve bu işi çok iyi
yapmasıyla övünür.
Ve çizmelerini satan, çiğ köfte tezgahını
kafasına takan ağa,
bakınız....
Nasıl özgürleşir?
Bu görseli bulduğumda,
Bu gerçekten de küçük,tabanı olan,
böyle minik, karikatürize bir heykel.
Ayağında ki terlikler de bu filmde
kullanılan plastik terliklerdir.
İlk kez Züğürt Ağa'yı mutlu görürüz.
Neden mutlu olmuştur sizce?
Çünkü aslında etiketlerinden kurtulmuştur.
Özgürleşmiştir.
Bir arkadaşım var, kendisi bu arada
yapımcı yönetmen. Bana dedi ki:
Yurt dışına gitmekle
ilgili birşey den bahsediyorduk.
Ya dedi: ″Ben çok iyi pizza hamuru
ustasıysam ve bunu hâlâ bilmiyorsam,
henüz bilmiyorsam...
Neden olmasın?
Eğer kendimizi etiketlerimizin ötesine
taşıyabilirsek,
deneyimleyeceğimiz şeyler
çok fazla.
Tıpkı benim yaptığım gibi.
Bir üniversitede 10 dönem
boyunca ders verdim.
Öğrencilerim 18 ile 19-18 ve 21 yaş
arasındaydı ve sevgili öğrencilerimden,
bir şey öğrendim.
Kamera önü oyunculuk dersleri veriyordum
ve hepsi Sinema Televizyon öğrencisiydi.
Ama bir de ek ders alan, Yeni
Medya öğrencileri vardı.
Birgün bir tanesi dedi ki...
Ben bir tane kadını takip
ediyorum.
Çok güzel içerikler çıkarıyor.
Ne yapıyor o kadın diye baktım.
Çocuğu var falan.Çok şeker.
″Allah Allah″ dedim ya
19 yaşında ki kız niye bunu
takip ediyor?
Bakmaya başladım.Şu anda
arkadaşım kendisi.
Çok da seviyorum yani o içerik üreticisi.
Birlikte çalışıyoruz, birlikte
işler yapıyoruz.
O gün benim aklıma düştü bu
ve sosyal medyada içerik
üretmek nedir araştırmaya başladım.
Hoşuma gitti, yapmaya başladım.
Son 5 senedir, geçimimin büyük bir kısmını
sosyal medyada içerik üretmek karşılıyor
ve o işimi çok seviyorum.
120 liraya saatine ders veriyordum.
120 liraya saat ve ders verdiğim eğitim
kurumundan aldığım hediyeye bakın.
5 sene geçinmemi ve daha fazlasını,
ve bundan sonra
kurduğum dijital ajansında,
kim bilir nereye gidecek olmasını
sağlayan işte eğitim.
Yani o fırsata kendimi açmış olmam
beni buralara getirdi.
Yani beni özgürlük heykelime kavuşturdu.
Bakın bir tane daha arkadaş tanıyorum.
Kendisi, burada çok iyi bir
üniversite bitirdi, gitti Leiden’de de
bitirdi Hollanda da.
Sonra orada çok bir büyük bir bankada fon
yöneticisi oldu.Kendisi aynı zamanda o
Hollanda dilini öğrendi ve vatandaşı oldu.
Ondan sonra düşündü ,taşındı,
işi bıraktı.
İngiltere'de çiçek tasarımı okudu.
Türkiye'ye döndü ve kendisi şu anda çok
başarılı bir çiçek tasarımcısı ve
düğünlere, davetlere, büyük otellere
çiçekler tasarlıyor.
Çiçekçi olduk diyor.
İki tane üniversite bitirdi.
Yakın arkadaşımdır.
Çok seviyorum ama tabii ki
çok zevkli bir insandır.
Evet, gerçekten kariyerini yaptı.
Çünkü şimdi çok mutlu.
Yine bir tanıdığım arkadaşım var, o
da mühendidi, jeoloji mühendisi.
Çok başarılı bir marangoz oldu ve
yaptığı şeyler dünyaya yayıldı.
Dünyadan sipariş alıyor ve yine
kurumsalda çok başarılı olmuş çok iyi
Kolej’de,Robertleri onları falan
Boğaziçilerini bitirmiş bir arkadaşım
ilaç sektöründe çok çok
başarılı iken yoga eğitmeni oldu ve şu an
çok da sağlıklı, neşeli, ışıl ışıl
bir insan.
Yine emeklilik benim şu iyi insanlar gibi.
Kime göre, neye göre emeklilik?
Emekli olacaksın diyorlar, insanlar
bütün yetenekleriyle böyle...
50-55 yaşında birdenbire kala kalıyor.
Çocuklar da okula gitti, gittiler.
Yurt dışında bir şey oldu.
Ya evlendiler ya da hoppa kaldı
bu tek başına.Ne yapman gerekiyor işte
″Emekli hayatı yaşayalım.″
Böyle bir şey yapmaya gerek yok ki.
Burada bir tane arkadaşım
var Saba Bener mesela.
O da gerçekten çok başarılı bir iş kadını.
Biz onunla şimdi birlikte çalışıyoruz.
Çünkü birlikte kurduğumuz, daha doğrusu
dahil olduğumuz bir girişimcilik işini
birlikte yapıyoruz ve gerçekten bunu
yaparken kendimizi çok iyi hissediyoruz.
Yani...
Bu hayat senin sevgili genç arkadaşım.
Ne istersen onu yapmakta özgürsün.
Bir üniversiteye mi girdin?
Okurken fark ettin.
O senin aslında istediğin
bir bölüm değildi.
Hayır hayatım.
Maymun iştahlı değilsin.
Sadece henüz ne istediğini bilmiyordun.
Ve şimdi belki de ne istediğini
bulmak için bir fırsat edindin.
Lütfen sadece ″Okuduk,
zaten başladık, 2 sene gittim,
o yüzden ailemi işte hayal kırıklığına
uğratmamam″ diye
Yani başkaları için yaşamayı
sakın düşünme bile.
Zaten yeni kuşağa çok güveniyorum.
Çoğu kesinlikle böyle değil.
Aslında yine lafım onlara değil bizlere.
Çünkü biz başkaları için yaşamamayı
çok da fazla bilen bir kuşak değiliz.
Ama öğreniyoruz.
Ben, bize, bir de gençlere
çok güveniyorum.
Teşekkürler.
(Alkışlar)